so you want to hear a story it has been
a long time hasn't it
so Kevin one of my ashamed secrets of
gaming is that I have never played a
single King's Quest game in my entire
life
though I am familiar with them but
yesterday we had a chance to check out
the new King's Quest and I was pretty
impressed we did and I gotta say I was
pretty impressed too there's a lot
riding on something like this when a
developer has this kind of storied
series behind it but it really looks
like I mean it's clearly a new game in
like a modern game it had some beautiful
hand-painted visuals for example and
they they talked about how those
backgrounds were actually created a
little bit when we were talking like you
know that the backgrounds would be would
be painted they'd put it through a pass
and then they do they do more stuff to
like paint and paint the background so
it all looked very painted and give it
another graphics pass so it's all hand
done it's not procedural it's not
everything is hand drawn and it looks it
looks like it looks absolutely gorgeous
yeah the water color thing is sort of
indicative of their design philosophy
yeah because it seems like everything
they're putting into this game is so
meaningful and full of intention and you
know you'll see a dragon from the
distance with an arrow in its eye and
you know most games that's just a badass
thing it's trying to look tough or
whatever like it's been in fights before
but no this is gonna like take you back
in that story figure out how that dragon
got that arrow in his eye and you know
make you choose and basically skinned
your own narrative onto the game based
on the decisions you make and that
totally came across in everything you
know like you see a lot of games where
stuff is just the stuff that looks cool
is just there because it looks cool it
doesn't mean anything not only does it
look cool but knowing that it's it's
meaningful knowing that it's not just
there because it's cool is is really
special to me I like they really want
everything tell a story and they're not
just doing it like like it's not just
like I get to devise the story they're
actually going to tell you that story
right and that's that's a really cool
aspect of the game yeah and they seem to
be subverting a lot of video game tropes
too which i think is interesting and
it's sort of pays homage to the history
of the Kings period and you know there
was a moment where if the
River you have a rope that's tied to an
arrow and you pull out your bow and
arrow and it goes into this whole first
person thing and you're like oh well I
aim it at the tree and shoot it to make
a bridge right and as soon as you do it
doesn't matter where you shoot it shows
a cutscene of arrow falling far short
you don't find another way across and so
it's it's it's it's storytelling it's
it's a great gameplay but it's also just
there's that humor in there that like
classic old-school game humor that I
feel like it's lacking yeah and there
was a lot of that kind of thing like
that
wha-wha-wha kind of kind of humor like
he does that that whole scene is really
awesome to me because what's happening
is his gold has been stolen so he can't
like he's got to figure out a way to
cross this big chasm and get over to his
destination and there are lots of other
you know wannabe Knights that also want
to prove their worth in this in this
competition and every time he tries
something tries a new way to get over
there what actually ends up happening is
that he he helps one of those
competitors cross where he's stuck and
finally when he figures out how to do it
one of the other competitors also
figured out the same thing and actually
crosses the river faster than he did so
they're really setting up this whole
idea where we're like you root for him
because he's the underdog and every time
he tries something like every time he
does something ingenious you know he's
the one that actually is helping
somebody else and it's it's really sad
and delightful all at the same time
because you really want to root for
Grant you really want to see him succeed
and instead everything just goes
horribly wrong yeah no absolutely I'm
I'm really excited for this game I I
don't get excited for a lot of games
like this but it just I mean it's it's
new to me too as someone who's never
played King's Quest so maybe this will
spark my interest I'll start playing
then reverse order until I reach the
oldest one
about a tail you haven't heard before
one with luscious worlds of wonder of
treacherous traps fantastical